important mais vous aidiez voilà une
image de merde là vous renvoyer une
image de meilleure valeur victoria c'est
juste qu'on n'a pas tous filmés en fait
on n'a pas passé la soirée sont au
téléphone c'était un cocktail on a dit
beaucoup de choses à fait je les fais
justement laissez moi parler en fait
j'ai fait une vidéo youtube où j'ai
absolument pas sauf si vous perdez
messieurs vous êtes très su en fait
[Applaudissements]
responsable de génération z calvados
était ça tout à fait aux étudiants en
licence de droit à caen ces salles
universal vu t'as vu ta tout de suite vu
sur les réseaux pt qui était voilà côté
tout le monde parler de toi je m'y
attendais en fait ouais y avait déjà eu
une première vague en fait suite à ma
venue au meeting de nantes j'ai tout de
suite vu en fait vous voyez dans les
tweets cité tout de suite les réactions
des gens est aussitôt j'ai vu que ce à
quoi
les tweets c'était beaucoup de tes infos
negro ou alors tu fais honte à ta
communauté nique ta race même on va te
décapité si je venais ici et donc j'ai
décidé de porter plainte donc je le
porterai plainte voilà ça commence à
faire beaucoup quand même et j'ai eu
peur même de venir quand même parce
qu'on m'a dit que si je venais ici on
décapiterait mais ici ici m'a dit si tu
viens à paris où elle là parce que c'est
le mot qui bavaient combat de décapiter
donc
[Musique]
mais je suis venu quand même et je vais
déposer plainte la cia ait pas eu eric
zemmour torres avait personne intègre un
candidat non non non on est moins dans
marine le pen non non non janvier pas de
candidat particulier d'accord mais eric
zemmour c'est aussi son courage qui m'a
séduit qui est le sien depuis 30 ans
c'est à dire de faire face à toutes les
critiques
avec le risque qui est le sien
c'est-à-dire d'être menacés de subir des
attaques et ceo d agression et j'ai
toujours été enfin j'ai été séduit par
le courage donc comme je vais le dire
chrétien il affronte toutes les
critiques et toutes les insultes qu'on
peut lui proférer tu as peur aujourd'hui
non pas du tout non non j'ai pas peur
non non à la tranquille dans la rue on y
amène tout seul et n'a pas demandé dans
cette sous protection non dans toutes
les menaces que tu as reçu ça ne touche
pas non honnêtement ça me fait ni chaud
ni froid
[Musique]
qu'on me rendais compte tenu des
contraintes foot la maman une légende
mon ami qui a donné du chili pourrait
commis parce qu'ils ont tous les deux
nous tuque alors
je suis parce qu'il y avait déjà une
première fois dans la ville a appelé le
délai vous gates avec tes your acquis
qui voit là avait fait rapatrier par des
locaux de la nourriture sur l'île
puisque lui est originaire de là-bas et
la révélation en fait les candidats
peuvent ils sont sept ils sont au nombre
de sept d'ailleurs claude qui qui voit
là un outil clairement que bah il nie
pas les faits bon il les affirme pas non
plus mais bon pour lui en fait et c'est
une vendetta contre le match parce que
c'est une grande légende et que certains
connaissent la fin du jeu et que du coup
bah voilà on lui en veut et aussi une
machination contre lui ça mais bon je
vais quand même utilisé le conditionnel
a pas parce que je suis pas sûr de mes
infos mais parce que voilà dr est donc
theora claude non ils n'ont sam non
laurent noro jade nom et kumba bon ben
voilà alors pendant savoir et vendait à
sion - n'ont pas combattu c'est que je
suis fou de poubara désolé quoi combat à
manger
à manger aujourd'hui pas ces gens ont
passé ça ses légendes ils ont mangé il
avait la da alors que
manger que bien manger legault n'a rien
mangé on chausse haut alors eh bien
parce qu'il avait lara sera souvent on
va avoir un moment quand on entend ça
franchement je suis dégoûté ouais je
sais je suis dégoûté parce que j'ai reçu
une centaine de messages ce matin de
beaucoup d'aventuriers de koh lanta qui
comprennent pas que d'être invité à ce
programme qui est vingt ans des légendes
et ils se permettent de faire ce ça et
avoir ce comportement là moi je moi je
tire mon chapeau à hugo parce que tu me
regardes chapeau franchement tu es un
bon parce que normalement c'est lui qui
doit gagner la france et en parlant de
vie est de gagner par nos excuses moi
mais je vais pas fouiller un peuple qui
chante pas en colère mais c'est pas
grave sourit
le jour de la finale qu'est ce qu'ils
vont faire quoi mais c'est ça que si
vous faire la paix ils ont donné le
titre c'est cbs
qui vont lui donner non mais tu as
raison ils vont avoir les couronnaises
dire ça fait quoi quand tu découvres
date pas d'hier constitue
un pré oui parce qu'ils vont avoir ce
courage de se dire c'est quoi on va pas
vous le donner oui on va pas vous le
donner on va en voir mc le titre mais
certes la raison
donc je sortais de ma salle de sport je
passe en coude un coup de fil
professionnels devant la porte de mon
ami est en fait je vais acheter adossé à
la porte j'avais mes écouteurs et jeu du
coup j'ai pas entendu qu'il y avait
quelqu'un qui est arrivé derrière moi
probablement j'avoue que je me suis pas
imaginer que ça pouvait être un individu
que je connaissais pas je me suis dit
peut-être que c'est mon ami qui revient
je sais pas j'ai en fait je sais pas
j'ai un instant de sidération et il est
rentré dans mon appartement a tout de
suite pris mon téléphone des mains que
je tenais comme ça parce que j'écoutais
de la musique vous retrouver avec
l'individu chez votre ami ouais seul
salut ils montrent pas de signes
d'agressivité de premier abord il a mon
téléphone il a ma clé donc là en fait le
seul choix que j'ai c'est d'être
d'attendre et de me dire mais je parie
sur le fait qu' effectivement je suis
pas il est poursuivi je ne sais pas par
qui et qui au bout de dix minutes il va
partir donc je donc là qu'est ce qui se
passe donc la danse et voilà vous restez
il reste à distance il reste pour
l'instant à distance au début ce n'est à
côté du canapé il me dit tu vois je te
touche pas dit qu'il est d'origine
tunisienne que ça fait un an et demi
qu'il est en france qu avant ils tant en
allemagne donc j'avoue que je n'aimais
pas trop la tournure que prenait la
conversation puisque il m'assure et
surtout les surtout est grand dieu que
si vous voulez pas de mal mais commence
à parler de mon physique de 2 voilà de
mon ma vie privée et donc je me
rapproche je me rapproche de la porte il
a posé mon téléphone sur le canapé me
dit tu vois je te rends compte téléphone
et où il s'approche et ils sont la clé
il s'apprête à la main il fallait la met
dans la serrure mais il est encore
devant la porte moi je suis pas et il me
dit juste juste avant de partir tu as
vraiment été gentil avec moi est ce que
tu veux bien me faire un bisou et là
jusqu'à maintenant j'étais resté calme
mais là je commence à vraiment avoir le
stress qui monte pas ce que je dis ça
tourne pas bien du tout cette histoire
je pleure je dit arrête un axe top jeu
va-t'en va-t'en tu m'avais dit que tu
partais et là en fait y avait un peu
juste derrière moi
tiens par les deux poignets il me faire
l'asseoir sur le pouf et il me dit calme
toi comme toi arrête de pleurer arrête
de pleurer et il me dit je veux juste
juste une chose juste une chose après je
m'en vais je te jure je m'en vais après
je te demande juste une chose est donc
voilà j'étais absolument terrorisé vous
demander voilà
je suis désolé papa maman que je garde
nationale étaient à ce moment là parce
que c'est pas agréable d'entendre ça
mais du coup bas âge je suis je le
regarde je suis terrorisée et là il dit
juste avant de partir juste justice us
hélas jamais facile aux plus belles et
j'avais vraiment super peur et hommes et
donc du coup mais je suis et il a en
battant ce que vous mettez à pleurer
j'ai fait tout ce que tu m'a demandé mon
nom ce thème les battants et s'ébahit
lima une même plus ou moins lâché j'ai
réussi à me relever
vraiment
j'ai eu à la porte et il est parti je
sais pas comment elle fait pour partir
parce que j'étais sûr qu'il allait pas
partir il y avait mon arrivée 1 % de
chances pour qu'il s'en aille je suis
désolé mais en fait moi mon témoignage
si j'ai décidé d'en parler c'est que
j'en ai assez de ce tabou que les filles
qui revient en forme
je suis mais je vous raconte quelque
chose qui m'est arrivé que je ne
souhaite à personne mais aussi toutes
les fois où j'ai essayé harceler voir où
on va insulter on m'a manqué de respect
c'était systématiquement tout mon cas
des non blancs et ça c'est en mai
n'avez pas le droit de dire ça en fait
non mais là c'est jacques laskar
katabira c'est du racisme va là bas je
vous remets pas en doute ce que tu avais
qui épouvante amis vous pouvez pas je
moi quand je vous entends parler je
pense à tout ce qui se passe depuis des
dizaines d'années on peut pas montrer
les gens une communauté c'est à cause de
ces deux c'est horrible personne
débat très important organisé entre la
ministre de la citoyenneté et la papesse
de la télé réalité était accompagné par
cinq candidates parmi elles victoria
maïssane isabeau l'ina wehrli dès leur
arrivée au ministère on a senti que les
filles n'étaient pas très rodé sur les
formalités et l'attitude à adopter de
manu sèchement alors par contre on
respecte le président de la république
voilà merci manuel et maniema oui bref
vous l'avez compris sur les réseaux
sociaux plus de vidéos qui ressemble à
un goûter entre copines que du débat à
proprement parler
de quoi faire bondir certains
internautes alors des candidats de
télé-réalité ont-ils vraiment leur place
dans un ministère d'un mec souza était
[ __ ] là bas vous êtes dit quoi long
mais on a parlé on a parlé de tout la
cause que l'on pouvait mettre en lumière
sur nos réseaux sociaux et savoir
comment on pouvait utiliser nos réseaux
sociaux pour une fois pour des bas nous
sommes avancées nous avons avancé ouais
vraiment on voit le niveau du
gouvernement il est vraiment triste je
crois qu'on est tombé au plus bas tu
plus loin on a le grand retour du club
dorothée maintenant dans un ministère
peut-être que bientôt ils vont tourner
les princes de l'amour à l'elysée je
sais pas comme ça les gens sociation
autour de la protection de la femme qui
y bossent jour et nuit le samedi le
dimanche tout quelque chose non ça me
fait déjà mal au ventre quand ma fille
est allé chez sa maman car garde de la
télé réalité où on apprend à nos jeunes
qu'il faut se faire grossir les seins
s'envoyer du botox et faire voir ses
fesses au quotidien moi franchement ça
me démonte de voir ça je crois qu'il ya
des gens beaucoup plus sérieux qui
devrait vous faire kiffer je vous ai
fait une petite compil
attend mais voilà une image de merde
leur hymne à vous renvoyer une image de
meilleure valeur victorieuse au les
rites nous parce que vous avez avancé
sur des sujets oui alors bien sûr il est
l'oncle soul était bien sûr c'est juste
qu'on n'a pas tous filmés en fait on n'a
pas passé la soirée sont au téléphone
c'était un cocktail on a dit beaucoup de
choses à plat fait je les fais justement
laissez moi parler en fait j'ai fait une
vidéo youtube où j'ai absolument sauf si
vous perdez messieurs vous êtes très su
en fait vous prenez vous avez une manip
assimile arrière est très méprisant je
parle blessés les femmes et vous
rabaisser les jeunes enseignants
méprisés mais on n'est pas des chiens
pour tout donner des femmes d'accord et
on agit on essaie de faire des choses
des choses pour votre cause nous il ya
des côtes au qu'on veut qu'on peut aider
aujourd'hui rien ne vous plaignez et
quand on fait quelque chose vous vous
plaignez
quand on est sorti de cette réunion on a
poster des liens pour aider des gens est
la plus d'un million follower outillage
ne serait ce qu'une seule personne
qu'elle a pu sauver hier grâce à ses
réseaux sociaux et bien je suis fier
d'être ridicule
comment vous expliquez le sondage à 91 %
de gens qui disent que vous n'avez rien
à [ __ ] là bas mais parce qu'il m'en
fous mais comment vous l'expliquer parce
que les jambes des codes ici c'est des
codes ou à la fois dans des castes et
une femme tu fermes tu te tais tu as des
faux seins t'es bête tu fais latéralité
will stop aux benjamins 4 a
servi de dire que non moi qui suis une
femme j'ai 40 ans je suis maman je
m'assume je travaillais la téléralité la
terre était m'a sauvé la vie et si moi
je peux aider et je peux sauver la vie à
des gens je le ferai de traces un
message si le message arrive mal faut
être honnête c'est qu'on l'a mal fait
passer au départ et je pense que
l'erreur il est juste là il est jusqu'à
lors des 90 on prend les gens n'ont pas
les approprient réveillez vous il ya 80%
la jeunesse
lagardère va regarder le sondage
révèle
que j'ai aujourd'hui dans le match on va
arrêter de dire des conneries on
l'aurait alors je préfère les mêmes
personnes l'audition de certaines code
vous avez pas me reprocher c'est quand
même pas voter bah ouais ils sont pas
voter non payés c'est de regarder si on
peut ouvrir un peu les mentalités
peuvant aller vers ces vagues à
remercier magali merci au niveau du
combat
je vais te poser une question et la
question devait être posée
je possède déjà la réponse à car
j'ai enquêté mes combats
je vais te poser cette question que tout
le monde attend je tape attendre plus
longtemps
coumba oui serré as-tu manger ça arrive
je te jure sur tout ce que j'aime plus
cher comme on dit chez nous un sonic et
wallah une bulle ex héritiers pas manger
j'ai pas mangé comme les spectateurs pub
et je vous jure j'ai pas mangé je suis
sorti la première de la réunification
comment tu veux que je mange là je vais
mener ma petite enquête koumba koumba
je vais donner des éléments aux
téléspectateurs qui nous regardent qui
se pose la seule et unique question qui
a mangé
et à manger
coumba
vous êtes arrivés sur l'île
et vous êtes reparti
avant les repas avant les repas
clandestins effectivement j'ai mené mon
enquête et fait koulouba était déjà loin
oui effectué pendant que les autres sont
piffrer
ce grand renfort fait confiant mais de
roue d'or et de port salut c'est
confirmé c'est une bonne raison vous
n'avez pas avantagés car j'ai mené mon
enquête combat vous êtes libre
vous vous sentez mavuba n'a pas mangé je
le sais aujourd'hui merci combat d'être
là hier pourquoi son nom est sorti
j'étais un homme baisser pour son nom et
sur l emballage et c'est bien là alors
elle est super même si mes amis c'est
réellement une armée parce que à mon
avis il ya eu il ya des gens qui ont
dicté avait mangé mais tu mets ça ne
concordent pas car les dates de ce
chrono de la junte ont mangé
chronologiquement tu ne pouvais pas
manger c'est comme si vercingétorix
sorte avec david guetta
[Rires]
j'avais envie de dire que peut-être que
comme on est des aventuriers aguerris la
prod avait beau et surtout lévis nous on
avait le tournevis son bar à les feintes
et puis je pense que la prod avait une
grande confiance en nous en se disant
les candidats on va pas les flics et ils
sont assez grands c'est des vrais
aventuriers vont pas aller chercher à
tricher mais s'alimentait c'est le
besoin primaire donc je pense que ce
qu'ils ont mal calculé leur coup et puis
moi j'ai envie de dire que la prod
également ici aucune animosité contre 8
chez les adore au contraire mais aussi
ils ont merdé dans l'histoire allait
mettre plus de surveillance en vérité
moi là on va exempter
c'est ça vous avez tongiens se retrouver
on va chercher à les voir parce que tu
rallye
la vérité ça s'est passé j'ai pas besoin
de répondre à cette question
[Rires]
la raison est la raison est ce que ton
vous candidature manger ou pas du tout
ah non je ne veux pas
son parti chercher là qu'ils ont trouvé
pour servir à la production d'avoir
honte d'avoir mal surveillées
dans l'émission la phase 4 chez amel
bent s'est confié sur son quotidien
depuis the voice elle a réveillé la ta
cible de nombreuses attaques racistes
sur les réseaux sociaux regarder ce
qu'elle a dit on en parle juste après
j'ai eu tellement eu l'impression que
déjà ma simple présence dans le paf au
moment où moi j'ai commencé ce n'est
déjà tellement politique en fait et je
le vois encore quand j'intègre le
fauteuil de the voice et que je vois les
commentaires du samedi soir sur twitter
je me dis et on a encore du chemin en
fait c'est cia tellement enfin c'est
tout le monde n'est pas prêt à voir une
rebuse sur le fauteuil passé négatif
commente un analyste sur ma mes origines
à wahiba farce device à alger ça veut
pas dire qu'on en est toujours là mais
il ya des gens qui en sont toujours là
c'est pas la france
c'est une partie de la population une
partie de la population qui n'est pas
prête encore évidemment c'est fou ça
mais c'est ce qui arrive c'est ce qui
est bien c'est qu'elle dit c'est pas la
france va bien je dise que c'est vrai la
raison la ramène alors les individus qui
sont racisme etc c'est que c'est pas la
france nommé vapeur the voice a et celle
qui conclut sur une prairie pareil on
les connaît eunice s est typique de
twitter c'est le réseau social on peut
lire le plus de messages haineux
racistes sans doute parce que c'est le
réseau social le plus anonyme et elle a
pris une très bonne décision c'est
qu'elle a supprimé tout simplement comme
ça ne regarde même plus elle atteint
plus longtemps mais pour elle c'est vrai
que c'est oui c'est pas la france mais
il y en a beaucoup il y en a beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup il ya encore trop il
faut les dénoncer à la raison il ya
beaucoup de roland rassis dans les
messages des réseaux sociaux qui ont
plein de bons est faible 1 2 bon côté
mais ça c'est inadmissible et il faut le
dénoncer c'est vrai qu'en ce moment
beaucoup de gens parlent de ça beaucoup
de gens parlent de critiques racistes
sur les réseaux c'est vrai c'est vrai
mais c'est vrai que dans la brousse
ouais c'est certainement compliqué
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]